i'm invisible that's where i'm going to
be i got heat all over me i'm not
telling you where i am
what are you going to arrest me people
please arrest me
[Applause]
you're under arrest
so why were you looking to get locked up
theodore everyone's trying to kill me
[Music]
they nearly killed us
what'd you do i did what i had to do
to get to you teddy
the legendary bob viddick you're a
psychopath
i'm a professional you pissed off the
wrong people
i'm gonna kill you drop that
gun no one kills anyone in here
you say you fell yeah yeah well to
clarify
i shot him in the head and then he took
that little tumble
hola
[Music]
how bad is it are you an idiot teddy
anthony lamb
i'm going by the more friendly and less
formal tonys these days
clear off my contract no candy this
contract is free fire
as there are competing parties for one
theodore moreto
bob we're gonna duel to the death
get me out of here always
and only about teddy
kenny
here they come let's make a deal man i
got a lot of money there's no deal to be
made
come on teddy you know how this goes
i need to know everything all you have
to do was let me blow
his head off when i had the chance
[Music]
not to help his man he's gonna die
i'm coming in there whether you like it
or not yeah
now you see the difference that is a
psychopath
[Music]
you